Localidades y el informe de PQR es página
web.
Lo primero.
el archivo que recibimos de la secretaría
general denominado informe especure
secretaría de gobierno vigencia o
corresponden del periodo mayo 2026 tal
cual como se genera se descarga y es
copiado en la hoja de Excel informes
Pqrs localidades mes de mayo 2026 hoja
reporte Pqrs mayo 2026. Entonces lo copio,
lo selecciono tal y lo copio tal cual el
contenido y me lo llevo a la hoja
completa.
Que tiene la base de datos PPT
localidades mayo 20 y 26 inserto una
columna entre número de petición y sector
para colocar allí lo que son los números
duplicados, los datos duplicados.
Siguiendo el procedimiento definido en el
Decreto 371,
reordeno toda la base de datos con
primero número de petición de menor a
mayor,
luego un segundo filtro o nivel por
dependencia de la a la Z y un tercer
filtro.
Por transacción entidad de mayor a menor,
aceptamos y aquí vamos a colocar en la
columna B,
primera fila con datos de la sábana,
es decir, la B 11 de que.
A 10.
Es igual a 11.
El resultado que nos arroja lo vamos a
arrastrar hasta el último dato,
arrojándonos que aquellos que tengan
datos que están duplicados y los que
tengan datos falsos son datos únicos.
Ahora sí nos vamos a la hoja que dice
informes localidades PPT en la en la hoja
de informe localidades PPT.
Vamos a actualizar todas y cada una de
las tablas dinámicas allí definidas que
corresponden a lo que está en el decreto
371 de control de PQ.
Le damos actualizar el origen de los
datos.
De las pqrsy me dice que me dice que
tengo un total de 1618 pqrs registradas.
No cambio ninguno de los filtros ni nada
tal cual los tiene la cada una de las
tablas dinámicas,
se actualizan y se va haciendo.
El registro por cada tabla dinámica.
es necesario que se tomen los datos de
cada una de estas tablas dinámicas ya que
hacen parte de el informe de pqrs
localidades no solamente de para
alimentar la tabla de resumen sino
también porque cada una de estas tablas
dinámicas es tomada por la compañera
Angie barrero
Para realizar el informe de localidades
del mes.
Eso no toma gran tiempo actualizarlas.
A.
Listo,
una vez actualizada toda la información,
nos vamos a la última hoja que se llama
resumen cifras.
Borramos el contenido anterior,
ese contenido desde el mes de abril.
Traigo siempre el formato predefinido de
cada mes. Borro el contenido desde la.
Pila B.
Columna B, fila cuatro.
hasta la B 26 y así lo arrastro hasta con
la columna acá eliminó todos los datos
que me quedé efectivamente en ceros y
empiezo traerme primero las PQR
sesionadas y las pendientes aquí en una
de las tablas dinámicas de info
localidades ppt encuentro esta tabla de
datos
Donde dice diapositiva 3 cuadro uno de 2,
solicitudes gestionadas y solicitudes en
trámite.
Traigo toda la información hasta alcaldía
local de Usme.
Lo copio en su totalidad y me traigo los
datos correspondientes.
Aquí hay que tener en cuenta algo,
la tabla dinámica ordena a la alcaldía
local de la Candelaria por orden
alfabético, empezando por la C.
En algunas de los datos,
Candelaria aparece como la Candelaria.
Entonces no figurará en tercer lugar,
sino que aparecerá después de mártires.
O antes de mártires por ese orden
alfabético. Listo,
una vez ya tengo los datos de cada una de
las alcaldías locales y teniendo en
cuenta que el Bogotá te escucha no me
maneja ni supercades ni un detalle de
nivel central. Las dependencias,
estos 3 datos quedaron inferiores,
el de dependencia a nivel central,
oficinas, centros disciplinarios.
Y oficina de atención a la ciudadanía los
voy a llevar en suma a la hoja de resumen
cifras.
Entonces me dice que en gestionados tengo
una suma de 8484,
cifra que voy a escribir en la pila B 24
y lo mismo voy a hacer con las pendientes.
Voy a tomar estas 3 últimas datos de la
columna C fila 226 27 y 28 que me da un
total de 497 y lo voy a escribir en la
hoja resumen cifra en PQR pendiente.
Al resto le voy a escribir cero cero y
cero. Listo,
hasta ahí llegó la primera parte.
En la hoja en el cuadro resumen me sigue
información de documentos extraviados,
orientaciones,
certificaciones de propiedad horizontal,
certificaciones de residencia,
encuestas del periodo de encuestas con
respuestas completas,
calificaciones de la percepción y
satisfacción de encuestas y el porcentaje
de percepción y satisfacción.
Aquí quiero hacer una claridad,
puede ser que la alcaldía local de
Antonio Nariño haya registrado 65
encuestas en el mes de mayo,
pero que de esas 65 encuestas solo 60
tienen respuestas 5 respuestas completas.
¿Quiere decir que la calificación es por
estas 60 completas?
Pudo haber obtenido una calificación de 4.
5 que tiene un peso del 85%.
Sobre el 100% si hubiera sacado 5 de 5,
entonces haciendo una suposición de que 4.
5 representa ese 85% de la nota ideal que
hubiera sido de la calificación ideal que
hubiera sido 5.
Borro ese dato porque este era solamente
de ejemplo. Entonces,
como su nombre lo indica,
debo traerme la información de documentos
extraviados del mes. Entonces,
ya una vez siendo descargados de los
archivos que generan los compañeros,
me voy a documentos extraviados 2026.
Siempre guardo una copia de estos
archivos por cualquier posible consulta
que se tenga que hacer y no se tenga
acceso a la aplicación.
Aquí,
al costado derecho de esa tabla de
registro CIDE,
voy a insertar una tabla dinámica.
En esa tabla dinámica le voy a decir que
efectivamente es desde la los datos que
tengo de la columna D hasta la columna
total.
Y que me lo deje en la en el espacio que
seleccioné.
Ya una vez dispuesto allí la tabla
dinámica,
empiezo a colocar que lo primero que me
debe traer es localidad en filas y que me
debe traer del total.
La información y me la coloque en valores.
¿Qué elimino de este filtro?
De este filtro voy a eliminar las que
dicen no aplica.
Y.
Me debe dar el total correspondiente al
periodo, es decir.
1723 datos registrados,
documentos registrados en el mes de mayo.
Listo,
entonces esta información es la que me
voy a llevar al otro lado. ¿Qué hago?
Selecciono la hoja,
le doy mover o copiar y me la llevo a PCB
de localidades en donde en la hoja que
dice registrado CIDE.
Lo creo como una copia porque siempre lo
llevo allá para que cualquier ejercicio
de validación que requiera hacer la
compañera que hace el informe lo
encuentro fácilmente.
Eliminó el anterior.
Y me quedo con el dato de la sábana que
acabo de copiar.
Entonces ya sé que documentos extraviados
este corresponde al mes de mayo 2026 y
esta información la dejo acá.
Listo, voy grabando.
Y lo mimo.
En el anterior,
en donde viene el origen de la
información para que no se me vaya a
perder nada.
Cierro el archivo de reporte resumen si
de mayo 2026 y ahora me voy con el de
atenciones.
Me voy a atenciones 2026 y abro el
archivo correspondiente a mayo.
En este archivo correspondiente a mayo
encuentro una información que ya está
generada en tablas y que es de gran
utilidad para la información del TPQR.
Entonces me voy a buscar atenciones en el
DPQR localidades.
Se llama registro de atenciones y lo voy
a traer tal cual está aquí resumido.
¿Qué necesito?
Principalmente el nombre de la localidad.
Y los grupos poblacionales a los que hace
referencia.
Bueno,
entonces verifico que efectivamente
aparezcan las localidades y los grupos
poblacionales.
¿Qué debo dar información?
Pues mover esto aquí.
Entonces aquí me aparecen los grupos
poblacionales y efectivamente me aparecen
las localidades.
Entonces esta hoja llamada tablas la voy
a llevar al de PQ o las localidades y la
voy a colocar en donde dice registro de
atenciones,
le creo una copia y elimino la anterior
sin antes cambiar el nombre.
Para que se mantenga la información tal
cual como está construida en el catálogo
de información de catálogo de activos de
la información en la DT,
no hay problema con que yo elimine las
que están antes porque no está amarrado o
atado la fórmula a hasta a los datos que
tiene cada una de estas.
Hojas, recuerden,
estas hojas las dejo solamente para
validación y ejercicio de la compañera
que hace el informe para que pueda hacer
el cruce de por si encuentra alguna
irregularidad. En este caso,
la hoja registros por punto de atención
está organizada de mayor a menor.
La necesito más bien en un orden de la a
la Z.
Para que me traiga en el mismo orden de
las alcaldías,
recuerden lo que siempre le he dicho
ahorita hace un rato de la Candelaria,
entonces valido que Candelaria está
efectivamente después de Bosa y ya ahí me
puede ir con los datos confiadamente.
Evidencio que tengo 2 localidades,
Ciudad Bolívar,
alcaldía local Ciudad Bolívar.
Entonces lo que hago es que tomo hasta la
primera alcaldía local Ciudad Bolívar,
le agrego el 2,
que es el que sigue del otro dato de
Ciudad Bolívar.
Y lo llevo a orientaciones.
Porque no he traído todavía de documentos
extraviados,
porque en el documentos extraviados no
salieron todas las localidades.
Entonces solamente voy a traer la
información de los que ya aparece.
Me devuelvo,
ya copié el 2 de Ciudad Bolívar y ahora
voy a copiar las otras localidades.
Tengo hasta Usme, bueno,
aquí me aparece un uno de Kennedy,
entonces asumo que es de la alcaldía
local de Kennedy,
entonces lo vamos a sumar.
Pego la información,
ya encontramos que tenía uno más de
Kennedy.
Si lo agrego acá lo coloco de esa manera
en suma para que cuando se haga el cruce
de la información se pueda validar que
efectivamente lo traje de lo que está
contenido en la tabla de datos de las
atenciones.
Aquí sí me separa nivel central y super
cada vez,
pero super cada vez lo tengo como un solo
campo.
Entonces sumo cuánto me da super cada vez
406.
¿Por qué si el informe de PQRS es de
localidades?
Tengo que separar lo que corresponde a
localidades y a nivel central,
porque en algún momento en los informes
nos han pedido que por favor le
discrimine de ese total de atenciones
cuántas se hicieron en localidades y
cuántas se hicieron en puntos supercadas
y en el punto principal.
A raíz de ese informe que nos pidieron es
que vengo ya hace 2 años separando.
Los datos correspondientes,
pero es que me dice que debo tener 4328
registros de atenciones.
Vamos y validamos y efectivamente tengo
4328.
Todavía aquí en ese dato no voy a tomar.
No voy a tomar los la discriminación de
los grupos poblacionales,
ya les voy a explicar porque se van LPQR
es página web.
Ahora sí,
en lo que estábamos haciendo documentos
extraviados.
Entonces,
en registrado dice que Candelaria tiene
96 y Engativá 98, Candelaria lo escribo.
96.
¿Por qué no está formulado?
Porque en alguna ocasión me aparecía,
por ejemplo, Candelaria,
así como está escrito en otras y
nuevamente enseguida me aparecía La
Candelaria.
Entonces él me asumía que eran diferentes
y eran lo mismo.
Entonces prefería hacer la verificación
uno a uno.
Para poder llevar el conteo correcto de
los datos, tiene 18.
No tiene 70.
Estos son los documentos,
la cantidad de documentos que ingresaron.
693.
Santa Fe, 15 suba 19.
Y te usaquillo 666.
Esta información es útil para las
localidades en el sentido que se les
muestra a ellos cómo está el ejercicio de
recuperación de esos documentos de
identidad para que puedan reposar en el
sistema de información de documentos
extraviados y de alguna manera el
ciudadano cuando reconozca.
O le llegue su mensaje de que ha sido
encontrado su documento,
pueda fácilmente recuperarlo,
re acercarse al nivel central y poder
reclamarlo.
Entonces ya recuerden que solamente me he
traído PQRs del Bogotá te escucha,
documentos extraviados y registro de
atenciones.
El mismo ejercicio voy a hacer para
certificado de residencia y propiedad
horizontal.
Entonces voy a abrir el archivo que
previamente ha sido generado por la
compañera encargada de Visalle.
Oh.
Listo, entonces ya con el archivo.
Arranco primero con el de certificado de
residencia.
Espero a que abra el archivo que es clave
en este informe o en esta sabanatos
generada de visa y la productividad por
el tipo de CR de certificado de
residencia y la productividad por cada
uno de los temas para asuntos para los
cuales es requerido el certificado de
residencia.
Nuevamente me dirijo a el archivo de.
Este de ya lo puedo cerrar al archivo de
localidades.
Y miro que me dice certificado de
residencia,
me dice que necesita por la productividad
de los que fueron aprobados, cerrados,
pendientes, rechazados.
Entonces no miro aquí,
esos se encuentran en la hoja
productividad cry esta información es la
que me voy a ir a llevar sin modificar
absolutamente nada.
Me la voy a ir a llevar a base de datos
localidades.
¿Y la copio, qué hago?
Cambio nuevamente el nombre.
El ejercicio de cambiar el nombre es
porque así está definido en los en los en
el catálogo de activos de la información.
This.
¿Qué me dice certificado de residencia?
Que yo tengo aquí unos datos.
de inscripción realizada actualización
realizada extensión realizada y
certificados generados Perdón estoy en el
aquí en certificado residencia tengo
aprobados pendientes rechazados cerrados
y total general me voy a ir con la
columna de aprobados eso es lo que me voy
a llevar a los lados
Entonces lo que hago es grabar.
Y reordenar.
De acuerdo a la primera etiqueta.
De la.
Listo y me llevo esta información tal
cual está,
donde me muestra las 20 alcaldías locales.
Silencio resumen.
Y la escopio acá aquí nuevamente me
devuelvo solamente para validar que
Candelaria sean 36 y no vaya de pronto
cruzar información.
Listo para nivel central coloco cero
super cada vez cero y en blanco cero.
Me dice que debo tener 6863 certificados
aprobados. Efectivamente,
ese es el dato que me aparece en el
archivo original del generado desde el
Visage. Listo,
entonces recuerden el archivo original no
lo modifique,
el que toque es el que está copiado.
En las la hoja de Excel,
denominada certificado de residencia de
productividad en mayo,
que es soporte para el informe de PQ las
localidades.
Listo como este archivo lo va a necesitar
la compañera,
entonces yo nuevamente me voy a datos y
le voy a pedir que ordene la información
de acuerdo a este porcentaje.
Entonces estaba.
What is?
Porcentaje.
Estaba de mayor a menos.
Yes.
de menor a mayor listo Ese es el orden en
el que estaba Entonces ya una vez
organizado como estaba el original lo
grabó y lo dejo así tal cual Ahora me voy
a ir a traer el de propiedad horizontal
Cierra un momento productividad de CR,
me dice que si deseo guardar los cambios,
no hice ningún cambio, entonces.
Ahora me voy a traer el de propio
horizontal.
Hago el mismo ejercicio,
entonces miro cuál es la información que
debo llevarme y recuerden que estábamos
hablando entonces de lo que estaba en
bandeja.
Lo que estaba actualizado,
lo que estaba inscrito.
Y ese resumen. Entonces me voy al informe,
puede correr PQRS localidades y que me
dice,
necesita la sábana de datos que diga de
inscripción,
actualización y extensión y que debajo
está por bandeja de correspondiente a
cada una.
Me devuelvo al archivo original de
propiedad horizontal,
miro que la primera tabla que está es la
descripción, actualización.
Y extensión,
entonces me voy a llevar esta hoja tal
cual.
A el de PQR localidades y lo registró en
el orden que le correspondía a propia
horizontal, cambio el nombre del anterior.
Y ese es el que le voy a colocar a la
nueva hoja. Bueno, lo voy a dejar abrir,
sino lo voy a dejar mayo.
Eliminó la del mes anterior,
no me afecta nada y la información que
está aquí.
Yo no me voy a llevar la de la primera
columna, la descripción,
sino que me voy a llevar al contrario del
propio de certificado de residencia.
En este caso,
la totalidad de certificados generados.
Entonces,
nuevamente hago el mismo ejercicio.
Lo selecciono, reordeno,
le digo que necesito que por etiquetas
vaya de AA la Z.
Ya una vez tengo la información,
me llevo la columna de certificados
generados, Candelaria está después de voz,
así que estamos bien,
verifico aquí me dice que hay 19 datos,
o sea que me falta sumapas,
entonces tomo hasta suba.
Me lo llevó al resumen.
En el caso de su mapas,
voy a colocarle cero.
Y termino de copiar los otros datos que
me faltan, que son tensa aquí,
yo Tunquelito, usa Ken y.
Ok.
¿Por qué su mapas aparecen ceros?
Porque no tiene propiedad horizontal.
Entonces nivel central cero,
super cada de cero y en blanco cero.
Es decir,
me dice que debió haberte atendido 809
certificados de propiedad horizontal.
Miramos efectivamente, hay 809.
Nuevamente reordeno como estaba.
Este está ordenado por porcentaje de menú
la mayor y me queda el archivo tal cual
como lo tenía.
¿Listo entonces hasta aquí que llevo en
el informe de de PQR localidades?
Llevo todo hasta la información de
certificado de residencia de aquí para
allá me faltan lo que son encuestas,
entonces ya eso es una parte
complementaria que ya les voy a mostrar
cómo se realiza.
Bueno,
continuamos entonces con la información
de las encuestas.
Se actualizó el reporte mensual de
encuestas.
En ese reporte mensual le sale una
información de las respuestas completas
más incompletas,
las cuales vamos a tener en cuenta el
total general para poder hacer diferencia
con las que tuvieron respuestas netamente
completas.
¿Entonces que nos hemos traído al informe
de rencuestas del periodo?
Las del total del periodo entre completas
más
más incompletas podemos ver que en la
fila que dice en blanco la fila h26 hemos
traído la cifra total de las encuestas
que se encuentran totalmente en blanco
listo porque no trajimos las otras de las
otras localidades porque esas serán
sumadas en el momento que saquemos la
diferencia para cada una
Ya una vez hemos traído las 3 las
encuestas completas,
ahora nos vamos a traer las encuestas con
respuesta completa,
entonces nos vamos a ir.
Al informe de localidades donde está el
total por localidad que se encuentra en
orden.
Entonces tenemos la primera tabla que
corresponde a canal virtual,
la segunda canal presencial y la tercera
canal telefónico,
pero vamos a quedar en la que reúne las
3:00 presencial virtual y telefónica.
Vamos a traer la información.
De todas las localidades recuerdan lo que
les dije que después de Bosa seguía La
Candelaria.
Entonces aquí en las encuestas vemos que
primero está Chapinero porque en las
encuestas Candelaria se encuentra
registrada como La Candelaria.
Entonces vamos a traer la información.
De las localidades en el orden,
teniendo presente que la Candelaria tiene
está en cuarto lugar,
traemos no solamente la cantidad,
sino también nos traemos la calificación.
En este cuadro resumen tenemos todo,
no solamente la cantidad, la calificación,
sino también el porcentaje.
Entonces vamos a traer toda esta
información.
¿Que es útil para lo que estamos haciendo?
Como en este orden sigue primero
chapinero,
deja un espacio para la Candelaria para
luego traer la información.
Y voy trayendo.
Lo que son las cantidades,
las calificaciones y el porcentaje.
Ahora sí me devuelvo un momento a
Candelaria, porque aquí en el orden está.
¿Por qué lo traigo de esta manera para
que precisamente asegurarme de que traiga
la información que corresponde y evitar
los errores de registros no correctos?
Listo,
entonces seguimos ya de mártires hacia
abajo ya está los datos normales.
Entonces los traigo hasta nivel central
porque los traigo hasta nivel central.
Recordemos que supercaves en la tabla
resumen solamente lo tengo como un dato
informativo,
así que allí lo que voy a traer es como
las cifras generales de los 7 supercaves.
Sí se tienen en cuenta precisamente para
poder hacer un control sobre.
Los registros que se llevan de los
supercajes.
¿Entonces,
cómo hago para el de supercaves?
Ahora en la parte superior de estas
tablas tenemos por puntos y por canales.
dividido entonces, por ejemplo,
aquí está súper cada vez en la fila 15.
Vamos a traer que son 139 las encuestas
aplicadas en supercas con una
calificación de 5.
Entonces escribimos la 139 y pegamos la
cifra que es de 5.
Y esto al obtener 5 sobre 5,
pues me da el 100% en blanco,
no tenemos información y colocamos cero.
Listo y de esta manera ha quedado el
informe de PCR localidades finalizada.
Con todo lo que se necesita actualizado y
las hojas de verificación que en su
momento llegase a necesitar la compañera
para validar todo lo que hemos venido
hablando. Bueno,
yo dije hace un momento que el de
atenciones íbamos a tener presente la
tipicidad de los atención preferencial.
Ese es para el informe de PQR sitio web.
Entonces vamos a ir cerrando el de
localidades porque lo hemos completado y
lo que hacemos es alistarlo para que la
compañera que se encarga de hacer el
informe ya pueda trabajarlo.
Entonces voy a cerrar a esta parte y me
voy a quedar con el de PQRS.
Página web,
cierro este también le digo que no guarda.
Y voy a irme al de PQRS.
Página web que es mucho más robusto,
más completo.
E.
Lo vamos a crear de ceros.
Entonces aquí yo tengo hasta abril,
yo lo que hago es simplemente que duplico
el último mes.
Le cambio el nombre.
Le coloco mayo 2026 y empiezo a cambiar.
Cada uno de los datos que tiene el
informe de Pecuar.
Dejé abierto el de PQR local encuestas
porque vamos a hacer ahorita una
validación de información entonces.
Recuerden,
aquí vamos a empezar ya el de PQRS página
web.
Entonces no sucede lo mismo que el de
localidades.
Tengo una hoja que se llama P reporte
PQRS abril 2026,
que es la que voy a reemplazar por los
datos que tengo de PQRS 20 mayo 2026.
Eliminó todo lo que tengo en esta hoja.
Y me voy a traer.
Mi archivo de PQR es como llegó tal cual
como llegó de la Secretaría General.
Entonces aquí lo tengo por el mayo.
Lo traigo.
Si pueden notar,
el informe original no tiene los
duplicados.
Entonces coloco mi sabana de datos allí,
cambio el nombre.
Mayo 2026 y agrego mi fila de duplicados.
Y lo bautizo tal cual, duplicados,
hago el mismo ejercicio.
Lo repito en este caso para que
precisamente no se nos olvide que eso es
un paso obligatorio de que nos pide la el
decreto 371.
Entonces no es cuestión de que si lo hago,
no lo hago, sino es que toca hacerlo.
Hizo una vez ya puesto aquí,
entonces vamos a decirle que la.
Celda a 10 es igual a la a 11.
¿Por qué no se hace eliminando los
duplicados que se podría hacer aquí en
datos quitando duplicados?
Porque necesitamos la información de los
datos duplicados para poder sacar un
análisis.
Bueno,
entonces aquí acabamos de copiar la
sábana datos de mayo. Voy a renombrar,
perdón,
voy a grabar porque ya está renombrado y
voy a eliminar aquí unas hojas que eran
de el análisis anterior del mes anterior.
Eso,
este informe web de abril es el más
importante que tenemos precisamente para
poder hacer nuestro reporte y tengo una
hoja adicional que se llama seguimiento
en días. Bueno,
aquí en seguimiento en días voy a colocar
aquí, le hago un monitoreo por cada mes.
Para mostrar ese comportamiento.
De los días de gestión,
estos días de gestiones por toda la
entidad donde me muestra las
extemporáneas, las oportunas,
las pendientes en términos,
las pendientes vencidas por cada mes,
el porcentaje de descongestión y las
extemporáneas que fueron vencidas y las
oportunas en términos las traigo de nuevo
en esta.
Tabla inferior para poder sacar el
porcentaje de temporalidad y el
porcentaje de oportunidad. Listo,
pero eso es algo que se que no va en el
informe,
solamente que lo saco para poder a final
de semestre o a final de año poder hacer
el comparativo.
Esto es algo que nos piden.
Desde alguna de las ias o a veces del
desde la misma secretaría general. Sí,
y abajo tengo en la una gráfica que me
muestra como ese comportamiento de las
PQRs. Entonces,
anterior a la hoja de reporte PQRs,
tengo lo mismo que hicimos con el de PQRs
localidades. Entonces me traigo.
de propiedad horizontal residencia aquí
en certificado residencial no solamente
está la productividad por el estado del
trámite sino también por los tipos de
trámite el registro de atenciones lo de
las encuestas lo registrado en el
documentos extraviados y lo entregado en
documentos extraviados aquí Recuerden que
yo les decía que teníamos algo clave
En el registro de las atenciones y era la
cantidad de personas por grupo
poblacional de valor.
Eso y vamos aquí entonces.
¿Qué voy a hacer con el informe web de
abril?
El copiar y pegar las hojas de los otros
reportes es lo de menos,
pero tengo que actualizar todas las
tablas dinámicas que están en esta sábana
de datos.
Entonces lo que voy a hacer es decirle
que por favor me actualice todo.
Cuando yo hago el ejercicio aquí me
actualice todo,
me va a decir que algunos campos de las
tablas dinámicas no son válidas y que
debo crear un informe para la tabla
dinámica usando los datos organizados.
Entonces,
en ese caso no me está dejando hacerlo
porque debe haber un cambio de campos de
análisis.
Entonces me voy a decirle que cambie los
campos.
Que me voy a dirigir.
Y voy a seleccionar todo lo que necesito.
De.
¿De qué de las tablas dinámicas?
Entonces aquí me eliminó el filtro de
duplicados en filas.
Entonces lo que hago es tomarlo y
llevarlo a filas y me va a mostrar
cuántos son registros únicos,
que serían 983 y cuántos son registros
duplicados, que serían 1636,
según la sábana de datos adjunta.
Las siguientes,
cuántos fueron registrados por el
ciudadano y cuántos fueron registrados
por propios.
Entonces nuevamente hago lo mismo,
selecciono toda la información y
actualizo.
Debo tener 2619 peticiones para este
periodo. Distribución por sexo,
este es una información que se coloca.
Verificando una de las peticiones.
Peter.
Y lo mismo,
la distribución por grupo poblacional.
Entonces nos vamos,
nos saltamos a la tabla dinámica que dice
distribución de P corresponde identidad
ciudadana,
que esa me la arroja de manera automática
la información la sábana de datos y sigo.
Trayendo la información que me están
pidiendo,
aquí me están diciendo que por cédula de
ciudadanía yo estoy,
yo tengo 1393 registros que corresponden
a personas naturales,
que por cédula de extranjería tengo 6 que
corresponden a personas migrantes
internacionales.
Que por ni tengo 145 personas que son
personas jurídicas,
que por ciudadanía con nacionalidad
venezolana, en este caso los PPT, tengo 5.
Sí,
entonces lo que voy a hacer es traerlos.
Y acá y decir aquí están mis 5 nacionales
venezolanos que por menores de edad le
corresponden a 2 que tienen tarjeta de
identidad y por pasaporte tengo 2.
Esos pasaportes pueden ser migrantes
internacionales. Sí,
en no especificas cuando no tenemos una
información,
este corresponde al que está en blanco,
entonces no especifica.
como un tipo de identidad ciudadana.
Entonces ya dijimos que por pasaporte
vamos a agregar dos más al de ceder la
extranjería, es decir,
al migrante internacional.
Entonces vamos a tener más 6 + 2 y vamos
a tener en total 8 los otros están
anclados a la tabla dinámica,
también la que si yo hago un cambio.
sobre la tabla dinámica,
pues voy a verlo reflejado en esta tabla
pequeña. Sí,
este cuadro resumen se hace para poder
colocar unos grupos de información que
nos piden desde la Secretaría General y
la Secretaría de la Mujer,
quienes es principalmente quien nos piden
estos de información.
Paso a la siguiente tabla,
hago exactamente el mismo ejercicio.
Voy actualizando las tablas dinámicas.
Cada tabla dinámica tiene un título
correspondiente a dónde va agregado el
esa información dentro de la diapositiva.
Aquí vemos que este cuadro está
desactualizado,
entonces yo lo que hago es simplemente
copiarlo.
los datos y me los traigo tal cual Por
qué me los traigo tal cual para que en la
tabla gráficas me quede actualizada con
la información eh Y pueda ser tomada o
capturada para el informe recuerden son
2619 peticiones de esta vigencia entonces
llevo ese mismo
Esa misma información en todos los
cuadros y aquí voy mirando uno a uno como
me van cambiando los datos al actualizar
cada tabla.
en esta tabla dinámica que estamos
actualizando que son solicitudes de
información dice que en total fueron 156
hago un cambio aquí manual le digo que
tengo 156 solicitudes pero solo las que
están resaltadas en amarillo son las
solicitudes de información que fueron
trasladadas a otras entidades escojo 28 +
una es decir en total tuve 29 solicitudes
solucionadas con un traslado
Que correspondían a información de a
solicitud de información.
Sigo con mis mis datos actualizando
tablas.
Así lo hago con cada una,
las tablas dinámicas que tiene este
informe.
Porque hago primero las tablas dinámicas
y dejo de últimas traerme la información
de las otras datos que van incluidos en
el informe general de la página web,
precisamente porque esto me demanda más
tiempo,
ya que tengo que verificar que traiga la
información.
Del periodo.
Entonces aquí actualicé en la capítulo 6
subtemas más reiterados.
Actualicé la tabla dinámica,
pero no he actualizado esta tabla pequeña
que está en la fila hy fila, perdón,
columna hy columna i aquí.
¿Qué voy a hacer?
Me voy a traer el total de esta fila que
es 12904. la.
De esa tabla dinámica.
Escribo solamente el total 12904.
Y me voy a traer los 5 más
representativos.
Entonces aquí me dice que en blanco tengo
3079 peticiones.
Eso no es un tema que me permita la
veeduría e identificar.
Entonces debo traer los que sí tienen un
nombre plenamente identificado.
El hecho de que aparezca en blanco
significa que hay algo que revisar.
Que en la clasificación está haciéndose
mal y que puede estar generando
interpretaciones erróneas de información.
La que está resaltado en naranja
corresponde a información de trámites y
servicios que según el defecto 371 no
debería tomarse en este reporte de pqrs,
ya que corresponde.
Entre comillas,
a lo que son solamente trámites y
servicios y que son manejados o de alguna
manera gestionados por el servicio de
atención a la ciudadanía. Sin embargo,
los copio los pego acá.
El por qué resalta en amarillo otro
relacione cuál en cuál en el campo de
observaciones.
Si yo quisiera saber a qué se refieren en
este otro.
Doy clic sobre los 535 y lo que me va a
hacer es mostrarme una hoja donde va a
traer qué fue lo que pasó con esos otros.
Yo puedo ver que en la categoría subtema
se está refiriendo a posibles actos de
corrupción, subtema,
otro relacione cuál es el campo. Sí,
y cuando voy a mirar,
la mayoría ingresaron por web service.
Corresponden a un tipo de derecho de
petición de interés general.
Pero es clasificado.
Y que de acuerdo a, por ejemplo,
a la solicitud,
puede evidenciarse que ni es un acto de
corrupción ni tampoco es un otro común y
corriente. Por ejemplo,
en este caso que estoy mostrando en la
fila 2,
dice solicitud por este medio de
certificado de contrato de prestación de
servicios.
Esto no debería ser un otro sino una
solicitud precisamente de certificación
contractual y que no debería estar
ingresando por el Bogotá. Te escucho, sí,
no debería tener Bogotá, te escucha.
El siguiente, Car Cundinamarca,
alcaldía local de Kennedy. Sí,
no dice nada más.
Luego dice respuesta número radicado
2575722. Tampoco dice nada más,
posiblemente sea algún derecho de
petición.
Luego dice la fila 5 solicitud préstamo 7
carpas 3 * 3 para el día sábado 13 de
junio del 2026 de 11 de la mañana a 7 PM.
De seguro fue una solicitud hecha a la
alcaldía local,
pero pues tampoco debería estar en este
otro relacione,
que es porque recuerden que la categoría
es la primera ramificación.
Luego viene el subtema, es decir,
el subtema va muy de la mano con la
categoría.
Si yo le digo que es un posible acto de
corrupción.
Y que el subtema es otro relacionado cual
en el campo de observaciones cuando yo
miro el asunto y dice solicitud préstamo
7 carpas.
En una lectura como lo hace la veuría,
dirá o pensará que la solicitud del
préstamo y las carpas fue posiblemente
denunciado como un acto de corrupción.
Entonces esto es algo que toca ver con
los compañeros que están haciendo la
clasificación. ¿Qué está pasando?
¿Cómo está ingresando?
¿Por qué se se mantiene en la categoría
de actos de corrupción?
De hecho de petición alcaldía de Urmi,
información, esterilización, animales,
solicitud, certificado laboral.
Entonces hay un mal uso del sistema.
Precisamente por este tipo de ingresos
que no deberían estar acá.
Sí, certificaciones contractuales.
Administración de copropiedades,
estudios y diseños para la intervención
de una vía, apoyo a la gestión,
derecho de petición,
reparación y mantenimiento de andenes,
traslados por competencia,
pavimen gente arreglar pavimento de la
calle, dan la dirección.
tú soluciona el problema causado por
falta de mantenimiento del espacio
afectado parque ubicado y dando una
dirección es decir hay al no le cuando
uno lee el contenido del asunto puede
evidenciar claramente que que hay un mal
uso de la clasificación
Restauración, adoquín, parque, bolsillo,
en fin.
Pero pues.
En este caso estamos haciendo un informe
de unas que ya se cumplieron durante la
vigencia del mes del primero al 31 de
mayo.
Bueno,
entonces ya una vez colocados los 5 que
corresponden a los 5 subtemas más
demandados por la ciudadanía, sí,
aquí no tenemos los que tuvieron solución
o gestión,
solamente como el total y más abajo vamos
a encontrar otra tabla exactamente igual,
pero estos fueron los que ya tuvieron una
respuesta definitiva.
Nuevamente hago la selección de la
información, ya cuando la trae todo,
hago el mismo ejercicio.
¿Entonces, cuántos tengo en total?
Tengo 4933.
Es el valor que voy a colocar en este
total en amarillito y borro los 5.
Más demandados para poder copiar esos 5
temas.
De mayor interés por parte de la
ciudadanía.
Neaster.
Seguimos, bueno, aquí el otro.
Está no está resaltado naranja y el de
servicios.
Me aparecía en tu culpa, listo.
Seguimos.
Es muy amplio el espacio que hay en esa
tabla con la otra,
porque a veces la tabla de los subtemas
es mucho más extensa y suele sobreponer.
Queda sobrepuesta a la otra tabla es en
este de tabla número 5 peticiones
trasladadas aquí enseguida y a mano
derecha un cuadro resumen cuadro resumen
me dice total de peticiones.
Entonces primero me voy al total de la
petición.
Pero veo que aquí hay un filtro.
El estado final de la petición libera el
filtro primero.
10599 es a la cifra que voy a traer aquí
la voy a colocar.
Y luego nuevamente voy a aplicar el
filtro que tenía,
que son todas las que hayan sido
seleccionadas por traslado.
Cuando ya tengo todas las solucionadas y
que aplico el filtro,
el porcentaje automáticamente se cambió.
Solamente tuve que cambiar el total,
que fueron 10599.
Sigo mirando hacia abajo.
Actualizando tablas dinámicas,
eso es en subtimas para veedurías.
Peticiones cerradas en el periodo actual,
que tiene un cuadro enseguida para
análisis.
Lo actualizo y una vez lo actualizo,
me traigo toda la información de
gestionados con una pendiente gestionados
hasta total de cuenta que incluya hasta
un mes, es decir,
las 20 filas y esa información la voy a
traer, la voy a pegar y aquí enseguida.
Sí.
Tanto las 3 últimas que corresponden a en
blanco.
que por lo general suelen ser las de
nivel central o todo lo que llamamos
nivel central está formulado, es decir,
ya él lo trae.
Entonces yo voy a tener aquí como.
Nivel central,
como lo teníamos en PQRS localidades.
Y en la tabla de enseguida hago lo mismo,
es la de periodos anteriores.
Actualizo.
Seleccionó todo.
Hasta vos me.
Y aquello que me aparezca en cero,
simplemente voy a decir que me lo
reemplace.
Que me aparezca vacío para que no me
queden a hacer. La última es,
como lo dije, ya está mencionada.
Entonces aquí lo que voy a hacer es.
Colócale el nombre nivel.
Seguimos a los días de gestión en días de
gestión.
Yo tengo resaltado en amarillo los que
sobrepasan estos días de gestión.
Le quito el relleno,
ese resaltado y nuevamente hago la
actualización al hacer la actualización.
Me pongo en el ejercicio de validar
entonces, por ejemplo,
en consulta que son 30 días,
cuáles superan los 30 días en denuncias,
actos de corrupción,
cuáles superan los 15 días y así
sucesivamente por cada uno,
resaltando cuáles son aquellos que están
por encima del tiempo leitados para ser
respondidos.
Derecho de impetición de interés
particular, hago el mismo ejercicio,
identifico aquellas que identifico que
están por encima las resalto.
Y la voy teniendo en cuenta.
Entonces tengo aquí quejas.
No,
ya sé que no puedo pasarme los 15 ya lo
que hago es resaltarlo.
Lo mismo enrechamo.
Halo.
Hola mami.
Spin on.
Espérame, Espérame, Espérame.
Terminé de seleccionar todos los que
superan los días de gestión definidos por
ley,
que son están en la parte superior
escritos.
para poder evidenciar Cuáles son los que
excedieron ese Entonces ese tiempo
entonces podemos ver que para el primer
mes de mayo lo que fueron solicitudes de
copia solicitudes de información fueron
los que más incumplimiento tuvieron sí
queja reclamo derechos de inspección de
interés particular Y eso es ser coherente
con lo que se
Con lo que en la medición que hace la
secretaría,
la debería existir en el siguiente,
que es muy parecido al anterior.
En el primero teníamos el número de días
de gestión,
promedio días de gestión y en el
siguiente lo que tengo es la cantidad de
PQRS que tuvieron respuesta.
Que fueron gestionadas y que de acuerdo,
pues a lo que se resaltó de los días de
gestión, tendría como la misma coherencia,
el mismo resalte a la tabla superior.
Entonces lo que hago es como copiar el
formato.
Y me lo llevo abajo.
Entonces es simplemente meter a los que
yo ya había resaltado arriba en la misma
ubicación y posición para la cantidad.
Entonces recuerden,
mientras arriba estoy viendo días de
gestión en la siguiente tabla,
estoy viendo cantidad de PQA.
Eso está explicado en el título de cada
una de las de las tablas.
Sigo bajando.
Esta tabla se sacó manualmente porque es
algo que nos estaban pidiendo.
Entonces eliminó el contenido.
Lo que voy a hacer es traerme los días
promedio de gestión total, es decir,
de esta primera tabla.
Me traigo este total,
recuerden que los 3 últimos no los tomo
porque los 3 últimos son tomados o
calculados como leídos como nivel central,
perdón.
Yo lo voy a pegar.
Macan promedio 10 de gestión.
Listo.
¿Y estos 3 últimos?
Si yo los tomo aquí en la parte que me
dice promedio, recuento y suma,
promedio me da 7.
Entonces ese es el valor que voy a
colocar.
En la tabla.
Aquí voy a colocar 7,
este valor también se se quita.
Para traer el que me arroja la tabla que
dice 5 para saltarlo aquí,
este espero que lo puedan ver.
Ese es el que me llevó para allá para la
tarde. Listo, ya ahora hecho eso,
me devuelvo a los 2 cuadros anteriores,
el de peticiones cerradas en periodos
anteriores y peticiones cerradas en
periodo actual. ¿Qué voy a hacer aquí?
Llevo las tablas solamente para alimentar
el cuadro que estoy haciendo,
están tal cual.
Aquí voy a seleccionar solamente los que
tuvieron respuesta definitiva.
Y voy a arrastrar los que son gestionados
para copiarlos en la parte inferior.
¿Por qué en la parte inferior?
Porque es donde estoy haciendo el
comparativo,
entonces traigo periodo actual primero.
Miro cuántos son los de nivel central o
los que se cuentan como nivel central,
me dice 3028 la suma.
Listo y sigo trayendo información,
pero antes de traer la del periodo
anterior,
libero el filtro que le hice al periodo
actual.
Digo, tráigame todas.
Aquí nuevamente le digo,
tráigame ya en el periodo de en el
periodo anterior tengo.
Las de respuesta definitiva.
Y seleccionó las gestionas.
Eso es para mostrar ese cierre que tuvo
el mes de mayo.
En cuanto a las peticiones que pudieron
ser del periodo actual y el periodo
anterior,
nuevamente sumo las 3:00 de nivel central,
me dice que da 458 y ese valor que lo voy
a colocar aquí.
Recuerden, después de copiados,
libero el filtro.
Y ya me ha quedado el cuadro inferior
comparativo.
Entonces,
en el mes de mayo se gestionaron 4933
peticiones con respuesta definitiva,
no trasladadas, no asignadas,
no en pendientes,
sino total respuesta definitiva que pudo
haber sido oportuna o extemporánea.
Igual están aquí ya incluidas todas.
Y lo que hago es diferenciar cuántas de
esas PQRS correspondían al mes anterior o
periodos anteriores y cuántas
correspondían al periodo vigente o al
periodo actual, es decir,
que se recibieron en mayo.
Listo, una vez hecho esto.
Si vemos aquí enseguida tengo una pequeña
suma,
esa pequeña suma es de el periodo
anterior más el periodo actual. Listo,
no la quito,
la dejo ahí para información de mi
compañera.
Llegó al cuadro resumen de lo que pasa en
mayo.
Entonces ya sabemos que en mayo fueron 7
días.
actualizo Esta última esta tabla que está
al frente está de tabla dinámica con la
información que me arroje me Así que
tengo 10202 días eso lo voy a escribir
aquí en la fila en la columna h y entre
periodo de peticiones del periodo actual
y s pqr duplicado voy a traer la cifra de
la primera tabla que vimos Cuántos eran
verdaderos Cuántos eran falsos
Entonces me dice que tengo 983 y 1636,
entonces escribo.
983 y 1636. Ahí me equivoqué.
Listo.
Y ahí ya queda escrito para el mes de
mayo.
Lo que se tuvo en el movimiento de.
Se me acaba la batería.
Ya vamos para finalizar esta tarde,
saco actualizo nuevamente las siguientes
tablas dinámicas,
saco la información netamente de las
alcaldías para hacer un ranking.
En este caso le digo que por favor.
Me reemplacé en el contenido de esta
tabla,
lo que di alcaldía local de me lo
reemplacé por nada.
Y con eso esta manera me quedan ya
escritos solamente el nombre,
me voy a ordenar,
le digo que ordene por la columna de
variables de celda de menor a mayor y ya
tengo la gráfica para participación por
localidad.
Me voy a esta otra tabla,
tengo la tabla dinámica entre las
columnas ABC y la que está en las
columnas FGHI.
Esa información la voy a borrar el
contenido.
Este es un cuadro resumen muy parecido al
que hicimos en el de PQR localidades.
O sea,
aquí lo que voy a hacer es simplemente.
Tener presente.
La información que quiero mostrar y aquí
va en ese detalle,
pues un poco más descrito.
Lo que se quiere decir,
entonces voy a actualizar mis tablas
dinámicas después de haber borrado el
contenido de la tabla resumen.
Y así lo hago para.
Las 2 siguientes.
Se necesitan actualizar esas 2 para poder
sacar la información que corresponde a
para el para el cuadro resumen, listo.
Entonces arranco con supercaz,
me dice que en CAE K 30.
Tengo 162 PQRS que en superk de calle 13
uno,
eso no es nuestro y en superk engativa
tengo uno.
Listo, de resto no tengo más,
así que el resto lo dejo con esa rayita o
ese guión que me dicen que están vacíos.
Y traigo tanto la cantidad como el
porcentaje de todas y cada una de las
localidades,
incluido a nivel central a este cuadro
dice ahí lo que hice fue como copiarlo y
pegarlo y lo tengo listo y no me voy a ir
a buscar 1:1,
sino que voy a traer la información que
ya traje en el cuadro resumen de poca de.
localidades para pegarlo en estas filas,
exactamente el mismo orden que cambia con
el cuadro resumen,
que tanto orientaciones como encuestas sí
va a ir detallado la cantidad por
supercaes.
Eso eso es lo que cambia un poco con este
cuadro,
pero antes de de quedarme en ese detalle,
quiero utilizar las otras tablas
dinámicas.
Para que sea completo el ejercicio porque
se va a morir mi batería.
Me traigo solamente el porcentaje una vez
ya lo actualizado.
Listo, eso me cambia la gráfica,
la dejo ahí, cambio esta otra tabla.
Me traigo los 3 primeros,
no me traigo la que está en blanco porque
esa no me no me da la representación que
quiero mostrar en la gráfica.
Y recuerdan cuando les hablé de
documentos estaría los entregados,
entonces cambio el título.
Mayo y voy a escribir aquí cuánto fueron
entregados a ciudadanos y cuánto fueron
entregados a entidades,
y lo mismo lo de los grupos poblacionales
de valor. Entonces,
como yo tengo ya eso hecho en localidades,
me voy a traer el informe de pqrs
localidades.
Para ahorrar tiempo.
Mientras copio y pego el resto de
información.
Pues lo primero que me hice es el
registro de documentos.
Documentos, documentos.
Registro de atenciones y el registro de
documentos, o sea,
aquí en atenciones ya tengo este cuadro.
Me lo voy a llevar.
Tal cual.
Para esta hoja.
Bueno, me dice que no debo superponerla,
olvidé que debo eliminarla primero.
Ahora sí me traigo la información, dice.
O sea,
aquí lo que hice fue un copy y pequeño
más. Ahora sí me voy a traer los de mayo,
entonces tengo mis atenciones de mayo.
Perdón,
las atenciones de mayo eran documentos
extraviados de mayo.
Y aquí me dice que tengo 23 entregados a
la ciudadanía.
Y 1269 devueltos a las entidades,
los escribo 23 y 1269.
Esa cifra no la requiere detallada para
el informe, solamente el total,
es como para un seguimiento, un control.
Eso hasta ahí hemos completado lo que
corresponde a.
El informe de PQR se te empiezo a migrar
todo lo de las hojas reporte para
validación de la información y me voy a
traer la información de certificados de
residencia,
propiedad horizontal y orientaciones en
el orden que corresponde a esta tabla.
Voy a dejar de compartir un momento
mientras pongo a cargar la batería.
Y entonces lo retomamos.
Entonces les decía,
tengo la información ya de los documentos.
Para no cerrar el archivo sin.
Sin que sin ser copiado en el IPQRS.
Entonces voy a traerlo al archivo que le
corresponde en el informe para correr que
entonces tengo registrados y entregados.
Entonces me voy a traer este resumen de
entregados.
Lo voy a copiar en de PQRS.
Si do it.
Y lo voy a colocar en donde dice
entregados, sí, creo una copia,
elimino la anterior.
Y cambió el nombre del que está vigente.
Aquí no le no le coloco mayo, así que no.
No, el hijo, lo mismo eliminó el registro.
Y me llevo el que acabo de hacer.
Que una siempre quiero una copia para
dejar como trazabilidad, listo.
¿Entonces, qué he hecho hasta ahora?
Traerme la información de el informe de
PQRS,
que es el soporte de esas cifras últimas
que coloqué.
Como informativo,
como dato en documentos extraviados, mayo.
Y voy a actualizar.
La tabla.
Esta tabla resumen que está en la página
web,
entonces el orden cambia un poco porque
aquí primero es certificado residencia,
luego propiedad horizontal. Yo les decía,
yo tomo una información que ya está en el
de localidades para no perder tiempo para
ganar tiempo.
Pues me traigo primero certificado de
residencia.
No está en el mismo orden aquí las
alcaldías,
entonces por esa razón lo copio a un lado.
Listo,
entonces ahora debo traer mi propiedad
horizontal.
Luego las orientaciones.
O.
Luego sigue las encuestas,
pero aquí no va a traer las encuestas del
periodo,
sino las encuestas con respuestas
completas.
Y ahora sí,
los documentos extraviados debería estar
en el mismo orden, se supone,
pero recuerden que uno el de la página
web obedece a lo como está estructurado a
la veeduría distrital y el de localidades
está estructurado de acuerdo a cómo lo
necesitan en cada una de las alcaldías
locales.
Listo,
entonces ya me traje la información,
recuerden que aquí tengo parte de los
datos que debo llevarme allá al sitio web.
¿Entonces, por ejemplo,
qué tengo en sitio web?
Tengo propiedad horizontal que ya puedo
eliminar de la página web,
certificado de residencia que ya puedo
eliminar de la página web.
Sí, y me va a traer esos 2 kg tengo aquí.
Tal cual los voy a llevar.
Entonces,
en este caso muevo para que me quede
certificado de residencia cerca tipo de
trámite.
Recuerden que tengo ya este lo puedo
eliminar.
Tengo el de certificado de residencia el
Excel.
El que viene original.
Para traerme el de la productividad por
el tipo de CR, es decir, este.
Para que lo necesite,
entonces le voy a dar copiar,
me lo voy a llevar a PQRS,
lo coloco aquí en CR tipo trámite, copio.
Cambio el nombre.
Y ya puedo eliminar este.
Listo, ya pensiones,
ya sé que se le ha actualizado,
ahora me faltan indicadores,
calificaciones de las encuestas,
entonces ya puedo cerrar.
Este y me voy a ir al de localidades para
traerme indicadores y calificaciones
totales.
Número copiar PQRS.
Eliminó los anteriores.
Oh.
Y simplemente lo que hago es tener en
cuenta.
Los nombres.
registro entregados pqrs info de abril
seguimiento días Ah bueno aquí en
seguimiento días yo les decía que traía
la información entonces en el informe web
en el resumen de días de gestión
Recuerden que lo tomamos aquí en un
cuadrito resumen lo voy a traer tal cual
Y lo voy a colocar aquí en el seguimiento
10 mayo.
No, bueno, aquí una pequeña aclaración,
y es que dependencias de nivel central,
si debo traerla como está detallado en el
cuadro resumen.
Entonces, me traigo esto.
5.
Sí.
¿Listo y de dónde saco estos otros?
Estos otros los saco de aquí de la parte
superior de la hoja de informe de web de
abril aquí a mano derecha.
Tengo estos cuatro cuadros o tablas
dinámicas y lo que hago es simplemente
actualizarlas.
Las actualizo para poder llevar la cifra
que necesito.
Y en ese cuadro, resume.
Y me falta esta última.
Entonces lo que está resaltado en
amarillito son los datos que me va a
llevar.
Aquí me dice es temporáneas y oportunas.
Esto me lo llevo al seguimiento de días.
Y lo mismo.
Pendientes y en términos me lo llevo,
esto lo hago para cada mes.
Listo, y aquí ya lo copié, ya lo.
El.
Me arrojó las cifras de lo que quería ver,
grabó.
Y ya me tiene la información total,
aquí me va haciendo un conteo o una
operación de lo que es el recorrido del
año. Listo,
entonces tengo esta información aquí,
esto es más estadístico y aquí tengo este
comportamiento del porcentaje de
descongestión que.
Debe figurar hasta junio.
Entonces aquí está hasta abril,
miramos porque no está hasta junio y lo
que hacemos es actualizarlo.
Efectivamente, está falta arrastrar,
perdón, está mayo.
Y eso es lo que me muestra el
comportamiento,
debo agregar la etiqueta de esta último
punto.
Ella me demostró el valor.
Pero aquí se me duplican algunos.
East.
¿Es decir, por qué?
Pareciera el mismo de acá,
muy seguramente este dato.
Tenía decimales.
Pero el redondearlo me parece como si
fuera una sola.
Siempre.
A.
Eso es más algo de.
De forma que no.
¿Qué está pasando en este punto?
Muy seguramente necesito ampliar los
decimales,
lo que yo les estaba diciendo porque no
es lo mismo.
El 90 que me da en abril.
Al 90 que me desmacho.
Si lo nota, mira,
899896 y seguramente si yo los otros les
agrego también un decimal,
ahí voy a tener.
Esa explicación.
Listo, entonces este es mi comportamiento,
el porcentaje de descongestión.
Bueno,
ahí ya grabo y sigo en mi página de el
informe web,
que es lo que trabaja la compañera para
el informe.
He escrito el PPT.
Es una vez ya aquí.
Que está en el orden que necesito.
12345 me llevo esto.
El nombre de cada una.
En el orden que lo traje de allá de
resumen para que me sea más fácil de
ubicar.
Sí,
habría una forma mucho más eficiente de
hacerlo. Claro que la hay,
y es que cada una sea simplemente buscar
el valor y traerlo.
Pero no me voy a poner la fórmula de esto.
Chapine.
Do the believe it?
Un momento.
Bueno, seguimos mostrando.
Una copia de la información.
Habíamos quedado San Cristóbal.
Santa Fe.
Suba.
Mapas.
There's a case you.
Tu Julitud.
Close again.
It was me.
Nivel central.
Y aquí es donde abrimos supercades y.
Tanto para orientaciones como para.
Como para encuestas, es decir,
estas 2 listo.
Me voy a orientaciones.
Y me voy a traer súper cabeza,
entonces 20 de julio, dice 16.
16 orientaciones.
Américas 40.
Bossa 70.
Vosa 70.
K 3013.
Engativa 11.
Manitas 143.
Suba 113 por cada virtual cero.
Ahora hacemos lo mismo con encuestas.
Vamos al Total.
El total dice entonces.
20 Julio, cuatro.
Américas 11.
Vosa 3.
K 3031.
Engativado, sí.
Manitas.
78.
Suba cero.
Y virtual cero.
List.
Ha quedado totalmente diligenciado.
El informe de IPQRS localidades.
Aquí una pequeña verificación.
Porque debía darme 3915.
Pues es todo hasta nivel central,
entre 1776.
Maybe.
Y super cada vez.
Media 124.
Y son 139, entonces algo falló, cuatro 11.
331.
1278.
Set you, sir.
Un número no me lo está contando.
124, sí.
¿Entonces, qué pasa con?
Si yo lo sumo solo me da 3900.
3776 me da su aumento.
3776.
780.
Muy bien, es algo en el formato.
Ahora sí.
Listo y para verificar orientaciones que
esté o k.
Me debe dar.
4328 meditaciones me está dando 3922.
Lo mismo no está contando las cosas,
entonces aquí 16.
40.
70.
3 sí.
Oh, sí.
143.
113.
Perfecto, ahora sí, ya me las contó.
Este es un ejercicio de verificación.
Solo por saber que todo esté bien.
Listo,
entonces de esta manera se ha terminado
el informe de PQR su página web.
Grabamos.
Y lo tenemos listo para.
Remitió la compañera.